keine ahnung ob es an ihnen
vorbeigegangen ist aber der neue
schuldner atlas ist da rund sieben
millionen deutsche sind überschuldet
trotz jahrelangem aufschwung
andere werden derweil ärmer weil sie
sparen sagt ja auch der aktuelle spiegel
es ist immer noch ein absoluter
kulturschock für unser land der sparer
ist offiziell der doofe ihr neues
kinderbuch ja damit die plagen sich in
den schlaf weinen wenn sie an ihre
zukunft denken
seit zehn jahren sind die zinsen im
keller bei uns und kein ende in sicht
ist aber bevor die wieder hochgehen baut
er tesla autos in brandenburg ja klar
klar dass mit dem niedrigzins das ist in
wirklichkeit eine sehr komplexe sache
preisstabilität fiskalpolitik wir
versuchen es jetzt mal ganz einfach zu
erklären
wir haben einen kapitalismus ohne zins
das ist so wie oktoberfest ohne bier
jetzt bricht panik aus
über zwei billionen euro lagern wir
deutschen wohl auf giro- oder
tagesgeldkonten die dank nullzins und
inflation langsam wegschmelzen sind wir
blöd nein uns fällt einfach nichts
besseres ein
abgesehen davon das lukrativere
sparverträge gerade massenhaft gekündigt
werden von der sparkasse ihren kunden
hat sie angekündigt seine geldanlage
umzuwandeln
die verzinsung dann laut preisaushang
0,001 prozent
und vielleicht hat er ja 3 milliarden
auf dem konto sind das bis zu zehn euro
im monat oder so ich habe nach der
dritten klasse abgewählt wir müssen uns
damit abfinden zinsen waren gestern
ja das ist fakt es ist fakt und so
größer noch riester verträge und
lebensversicherungen dahin wenn ich da
an meine kindheit zurückdenken worüber
man sich 1974 noch aufgeregt hat das
sparbuch erlebt eine renaissance
der zins ist mit 5,5 prozent zwar
niedrig über das geld kann aber
kurzfristig verfügt werden 5,5 v niedrig
ja ja damals als die meldung kam da ist
mir vor schreck die palomino jeans in
die kette von bonanza fahrrad gekommen
meine damen und herren ja niedrig von
wegen spare in der zeit dann hast du in
der not das gibt es nicht mehr
diese alte farbe von der grille und der
ameise die muss man komplett umschreiben
da sitzt die grille den ganzen sommer
auf der wiese und spielt geige kommt die
ameise und sagt ey du faules ei man kann
doch nicht den ganzen sommer nur fibeln
da hast du völlig recht ameise ab und zu
muss man natürlich auch mal einen
durchziehen
mach mal genauso weiter grille dann
wirst du im winter verhungern schimpft
die ameise ich spare weiter für
schlechte zeiten später im winter fällt
der grille auf dass sie überhaupt nichts
zu fassen hat also ruft sie ihre bank
annimmt einen fetten kredit für alberne
0,2 prozent zinsen aufkauf von dem geld
aktien und überwintert im luxushotel
geile sache die ameise dagegen hat ihre
ganzen körner auf dem festgeldkonto
angelegt totale scheiße jetzt ist die
doofe ameise total verbittert tritt die
afg ein und leitet den rest ihres lebens
unter erektionsstörungen
[Applaus]
bis heute
wir leben in seltsamen zeiten
gleichzeitig erlebt nämlich das gute
alte bargeld ein überraschendes comeback
banken die angst vor den hohen gebühren
der ezb haben und privatleute horten
tonnenweise scheine und zwar ganz wie
ganz früher in tresoren also oldschool
weil sie dem bankensystem nicht mehr
trauen demnächst und das jetzt kein witz
wird vielleicht sogar ein 10.000 euro
schein eingeführt weil er weniger platz
braucht im safe sogar kaputtes bargeld
wird hier recycelt des öfteren haben wir
auch ein gleiches geld welches klein
geschnitten oder zerrissen wurde meist
von älteren mitbürgern die entweder
vielleicht schon etwas in ihm sind oder
auch nichts vererben möchten auf dem
sterbebett so bevor ihr arschlöcher als
erreiche ich lieber und tausend stücke
als letzte amtshandlung so und wer ist
jetzt schuld am niedrigzins elend da
zeigen unsere politiker die deutschen
gerne mit dem finger auf die europäische
zentralbank die ezb neuerdings ja
geleitet von der stets braun gebrannten
christine lagarde
ja ja und jetzt mit dem finger zeigen
ist blöd dabei profitiert die gruppe und
auch selber ohne ende von niedrigzins
wir müssten uns bürgern halt mal was
abgeben von ihren fetten überschüssen in
dem sie endlich weise den massiv in
infrastruktur und digitalisierung
investieren wann wachen die auf eine
schreckensmeldung jagt hier auf den
wirtschaftsseiten die nächste habe das
gelesen diese woche deutschland hat
offiziell neun milliarde weniger
ja sie haben ganz richtig gehört diese
leute sind nur noch einfache millionäre
lachen sie nicht wissen sie wie
demütigend das ist wenn man mit einem
nur noch dreistelligen millionen
vermögen auf die alten milliardärs
kollegen trifft diese ganze häme es
schlimm
traurig traurig beim wachstum ist
deutschland nicht mehr lokomotive
sondern sorgenkind europas reden wir
drüber
mit einem der wenigen finanzexperten die
wir uns leisten können mit olaf schubert
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oder
die niedrigzins als dauerzustand was
bedeutet das für uns deutsche die doch
immer so gerne gespart haben tja es
bedeutet das sparbuch ist obsolet das
muss man sagen aber der deutsche sparer
ist ja entbehrungen gewohnt also er
musste sich jetzt nicht nur von den
zinsen verabschieden sondern auch schon
von der d-mark von wetten dass vom
sudetenland und ich beobachte aber vor
allem dass viele bürger gar nicht mehr
gewillt sind zu sparen das macht mir
sorgen also vor allen dingen junge
familien der würdige kohle auf den kopf
gehauen da wird das geld einfach
verordnet da wird es geld verprasst für
nebenkosten für mieter für kita gebühren
da wird einfach ins blaue rein gelebt
und das sind nicht leichtsinnig muss ich
sagen
also ich rate immer denjenigen die wenig
haben wirklich mal geld in die hand zu
nehmen und dann festhalten was was
redest du denn unseren zuschauern die ja
auch ratlos sind die soll man sein geld
anlegen aktien immobilien was ist der
richtige mix augenmaß das wichtigste ist
wirklich augenmaß ich kann jetzt auch
nicht einfach 100.000 euro irgendwo hier
reinstecken
du kannst das vielleicht ich weiß nicht
so also für mich sind 100000 euro viel
geld
dafür muss ich fast eine woche arbeiten
und mir ist nachhaltigkeit natürlich
wichtig man kann mittlerweile mit
finanzprodukten und nachhaltig die
nachhaltig wirken geld verdienen das
meiste natürlich mit finanzprodukten die
nachhaltig schädlich sind da gibt es
interessante angebot unterschied bitcoin
ja also bitcoin birgt große chancen
natürlich auch risiken
das ist ganz klar also den konservativen
anleger rate ich von bitcoin ab da rate
ich eher zum bitburger
ja da hast du schon mal hier prozent
sicher das wichtigste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diversifizieren aber wie man ja in
deutschland sagte blicken also da mache
ich es wirklich wie die profis aufteilen
das ist wirklich das wichtigste
also 50 prozent fonds und 50 prozent
immobilien und 50 prozent aktien nur
einige lachen
ich bin natürlich kein idiot weil da
sind 30 prozent übrig und die kriegt
meine frau gesagt ich würde
wir haben es auch schon eben gesagt bei
einigen zerbröselt wegen der
niedrigzinsen auch die altersvorsorge
was sein team ii sollte man fürs alter
vorsorgen
ich finde das ist in assen eine sache
der gemeinschaft der gesellschaft
deshalb unterstütze ich auch die die
grundrente bei allen wettbewerb es geht
nur gemeinsam man ist auf menschen
angewiesen es geht nur miteinander
ich werde hier mit jahre hatten sich
selbst als milliardär musst du dich auf
menschen verlassen die muss ja darauf
vertrauen dass dein leibkoch dir jetzt
nicht in einen topf tagtäglich so und
rentner brauchen sicherheit ja wenn die
nichts mehr verdient wenn die sich dann
selber kümmern also ich kann nur sagen
altus kriminalität ist skrupellos
denn sie kennt kein morgen und es gibt
immer mehr rentner also die die
bevölkerungspyramide nach unten jung und
alt sie ist gesprächen jetzt haben wir
ja bevölkerungsteil soll die alten sind
elastisch mopsfidel das ist das motto
null bock auf friedhof und ich plädiere
deshalb nach den nieten deckel jetzt für
den alters deckel also quasi würde also
mit 65 ist schluss ich meine ich bin
jetzt hier und 20 und 40 jahre reicht
natürlich aus so und altersvorsorge es
gibt nur eine wirklich sichere es sind
die kinder wie habe ich schon vor zehn
jahren gesagt übst du dich heute
geschlechtlich in askese schlägt sich im
alter ein chinese und wenn wir keine
kinder zeugen trägt deine paare ein
bulgare
denkt mal drüber nach olaf schubert
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und klickt im moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]